Transcriptor: Sheri Friedman
Revisor: Daniela Pardo
Nuestro presente es fantástico.
Para venir al anfiteatro,
le cargamos nafta al auto
el motor la usa, desaparece
y en pocos minutos estamos acá.
¿Tenemos sed?
Tomamos una bebida
de una botella plástica,
práctica, liviana.
La terminamos,
la tiramos y desaparece
Inclusive podemos usar un sorbete
que es cómodo, higiénico
y de un único uso.
También lo tiramos y desaparece.
Todo esto definitivamente fantástico,
porque, en parte, es una fantasía.
Ni la botella ni el sorbete
desaparecieron.
Seguramente se van a acumular
en algún basural,
o peor aún, van a terminar
en el río o en el mar.
El motor no hizo desaparecer la nafta,
sino que la transformó en distintos gases,
algunos con efecto invernadero.
El desafío que tenemos hoy
al desarrollar nuevas tecnologías
es conservar las comodidades
de nuestro estilo de vida
pero sin afectar al medio ambiente,
en forma sustentable.
Los plásticos derivados del petróleo
son livianos, duraderos, económicos
y por eso han revolucionado
nuestro estilo de vida.
Su masiva producción
en las últimas décadas
que alcanza al orden de los
350 millones de toneladas por año,
ha llevado a su acumulación
en todos los nichos,
especialmente el acuático,
afectando a la fauna de todo el planeta.
Un avance es el reciclado de los plásticos
pero esto es laborioso,
no es tan económico
y cada tipo de plástico
se tiene que recuperar por separado.
Menos del 10 % de los plásticos
que se descartan se reciclan.
Otro avance superador
es el de los bioplásticos,
que en lugar de provenir del petróleo
se originan principalmente
en el almidón y el azúcar de las plantas.
Entonces son sustentables, renovables.
Pero muchos de ellos
no son biodegradables.
Menos del 1 % de los plásticos
que se producen son bioplásticos,
principalmente por su costo.
Con respecto a los combustibles fósiles,
como el carbón, el gas y el petróleo,
han permitido el transporte,
la generación de electricidad,
la industrialización.
Son nuestra principal fuente de energía.
Pero con los años,
nos hemos dado cuenta
de que esta combustión continua
está generando gases
de efecto invernadero,
está causando polución
en los grandes centros poblados
y otros problemas de salud.
Un avance significativo
es el de los biocombustibles,
que en lugar de obtenerse
de las profundidades,
son reservas en
las profundidades del planeta,
se generan a partir de vegetales.
A partir del dióxido de carbono del aire
y de la energía solar,
podemos cultivar oleaginosas como la soja
de las cuales obtenemos aceite.
O maíz y caña, a partir de los cuales
se obtienen almidón y azúcar.
En un proceso industrial,
a partir del aceite de la soja,
podemos obtener biodiesel
que se puede utilizar justamente
en los motores diesel.
Y a partir del almidón y el azúcar,
podemos obtener bioalcohol
que se puede mezclar
con las naftas comunes.
Esto es muy bueno.
Son soluciones sustentables y renovables.
Pero con el aumento de escala,
porque se están utilizando mucho,
se están empezando a acumular
algunos residuos o subproductos.
De la industria del biodiesel
se genera glicerina cruda.
Por cada tonelada de aceite
que se utiliza para generar biodiesel,
se acumulan 100 kilogramos
de esta glicerina cruda,
que está contaminada con metanol,
sales y algunos compuestos orgánicos.
Todo esto dificulta su uso posterior.
Y de la industria del alcohol
se generan vinazas.
Por cada litro de alcohol que se produce,
se generan cinco o más litros de vinaza.
En el caso de caña,
esta vinaza se utiliza
para regar y fertilizar los campos,
pero como tiene un alto contenido salino,
solo una pequeña fracción se puede usar
y el resto hay que tirarlo
con el impacto ambiental que tiene.
Como ven,
todos los avances y todas
estas soluciones son parciales.
Para realmente alcanzar
lo que estamos buscando,
necesitamos un nuevo paradigma
que es la bioeconomía
o economía circular.
¿En qué consiste esto?
En aprovechar los residuos
o subproductos de algún proceso,
como punto de partida o materia prima
para otro proceso que los aproveche.
Y a eso nos dedicamos en una empresa
que hemos fundado
dos investigadores del CONICET,
junto con un grupo inversor
en biotecnología.
Lo que les voy a mostrar es un desarrollo
que ataca los dos problemas
que les estuve contando:
la acumulación de los residuos
de la industria de los combustibles
de segunda generación
y el tema de los plásticos
que no se pueden reciclar.
Lo que hemos hecho es generar bacterias
que se alimentan de estos residuos
de la vinaza y de la glicerina cruda
y los transforman en un bioplástico.
Este material se llama
PHA o polihidroxialcanoato
y es 100 % biodegradable,
tanto en tierra
como en un río o en el mar.
Sus propiedades se parecen
a las del polipropileno
que es parte de las botellas
plásticas típicas.
¿Cómo hicimos esto?
En la naturaleza,
hay bacterias que producen PHA
como su forma de reserva.
Pero solo lo hacen en ciertas condiciones
y en forma poco eficiente.
Entonces de esas bacterias
extrajimos su ADN,
la información genética.
Dentro de ese ADN,
seleccionamos los genes
con las instrucciones para fabricar PHA
y esos genes se los pusimos
a otra bacteria que es de uso industrial.
O sea, que crece rápido
y en forma eficiente.
A esa bacteria también la optimizamos
para que no haga otros subproductos
que habitualmente hace,
por ejemplo: ácido acético, ácido láctico,
y le eliminamos las instrucciones
para hacer esos productos.
De esta forma,
hemos obtenido una bacteria que acumula
más de 75 % de su peso en plástico,
que es lo blanco que se ve
en el interior de las bacterias
en esta microfotografía
que está señalado por la flecha.
¿Cómo llevamos adelante esto?
Hemos montado plataformas tecnológicas
para editar el genoma de las bacterias,
o sea, agregarle o quitarle
instrucciones para que trabajen.
Para cultivarlas,
o sea, multiplicarlas en
condiciones similares a las industriales
para ir ya pensando
en escalar un proyecto.
Y principalmente medimos
todos los productos que generan
y todos los metabolitos que sintetizan.
¿Para qué? Para saber si le falta algo
para trabajar mejor para producir plástico
o si está produciendo compuestos
que no nos interesan.
Con esa información volvemos a editar
el genoma de la bacteria
para agregar o quitar instrucciones.
Este ciclo lo repetimos
hasta que maximizamos
la producción de bioplásticos.
Y una vez que alcanzamos ese punto,
procedemos a purificar
y escalar los procesos.
En este momento, tenemos un proceso
que ya alcanzó
un punto de industrialización
y ahora nos estamos dedicando
a generar aplicaciones
y el mercado para estos bioplásticos.
Como son más costosos
que los plásticos derivados del petróleo
estamos apuntando
a dos tipos de soluciones:
aquellas en las que las normas
impidan el uso de materiales
que no sean biodegradables
o aquellas en que el hecho
de que el plástico sea biodegradable
implica un ahorro extra
para el que lo utiliza.
En el primer caso,
tenemos, por ejemplo, los sorbetes
que hoy en día están prohibidos
en muchas ciudades,
especialmente las costeras,
porque son plásticos de un único uso
y que tienen mucho impacto ambiental.
Si el plástico está hecho
de un material biodegradable,
sí se puede utilizar
y el hecho de que se utilice o que venga
en una gaseosa en un combo,
que es algo muy costoso,
implica que unos pocos centavos
que uno le agregue al sorbete
no tiene un efecto sobre el precio
del combo que uno está comprando.
¿Por qué recalco la parte económica?
Porque para que esta tecnología,
como cualquier otra, se implemente
tiene que ser rentable.
Y tiene que justificar la inversión
de aquel que decide
apostar a esta tecnología,
que la va a poder recuperar.
A lo otro que estamos apuntando
es a los envases de insumos agropecuarios,
como los herbicidas.
Hoy las normas obligan
a que cada uno de estos envases
tenga que ser lavado tres veces
y devuelto a origen.
Esto es laborioso e implica
camiones transportando plástico vacío
con el impacto y el costo
que tiene sobre el ambiente.
Si el bidón está hecho
de un material biodegradable
se puede enterrar directamente en el campo
y en pocos meses no queda nada,
ahorrándose el lavado y el transporte.
Ese ahorro para el productor agropecuario
justifica que el envase
valga un poco más que el que viene
de plástico derivado del petróleo.
Para que todas estas
soluciones se implementen
no alcanza solamente con investigadores,
emprendedores e inversores.
Hacen falta políticas públicas definidas
que estimulen el desarrollo
y la adopción de estas tecnologías.
De nuestra parte, estamos más que ansiosos
porque esta capacidad que tenemos
de transformar residuos agroindustriales
en materiales amigables
con el medio ambiente
se industrialice lo antes posible.
De esa forma,
vamos a pasar a vivir
en un mundo fantástico y sustentable.
Donde este sorbete
que sí es 100 % biodegradable
se pueda tirar y desaparecer.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)